major Supreme Court decision the Supreme
Court has affirmed Donald Trump's travel
ban number three that's what I call it
the third iteration it was a five to
four decision in favor Anthony Kennedy
as usual being the sort of ambiguous
vote all along but ultimately the courts
saying like it or not
Trump has the authority to in state this
narrower third version of the travel ban
it will be allowed to stand and if you
were having trouble keeping track of
what was version one two and three this
version of the ban upholds the
restriction on people from Iran North
Korea Syria Libya Yemen Somalia and
Venezuela from coming to the United
States and you might notice that people
from those states from those countries
have been involved in almost no violent
or terrorist acts on US soil ever I
think something like three of the more
than 200 total sort of incidents that
are categorized in this way had anything
to do with individuals from those
countries which raises the question why
are those countries the ones that were
chosen and how do you justify if you
believe in this type of legislation how
do you justify Saudi Arabia not being on
the list even North Korea I thought
North Korea was our friend now how will
banning North Koreans from coming to the
United States go over with Trump's buddy
Kim jong-un maybe unrelated news may be
related we'll dig into it more tomorrow
but there are reports now that North
Korea is actually escalating nuclear
research rather than denuclearizing but
the justification legally from the court
was that this is a an executive order
from Trump that it was based on national
security and as such supersedes the
importance of any comments that Trump
may have made during the campaign about
his real motive for passing this
restriction which was to ban Muslims
from coming to the United States and I'm
actually
really concerned about that part of the
decision I want to put a couple notes
from the decision up on the screen for
you in section 3 of the decision the
majority opinion said quote the
president found that it was in the
national interest to restrict entry of
aliens who could not be vetted with
adequate information both to protect
national security and public safety and
to induce improvement by their home
countries and then in Section 4 the
Supreme Court's decision says but
because there is persuasive evidence
that the entry suspension has a
legitimate grounding and national
security concerns quite apart from any
religious hostility we must accept that
independent justification what this says
is that despite Donald Trump publicly
proclaiming from almost day one of his
presidential campaign that the real goal
of this is to ban Muslims from coming to
the United States the mere citing in the
order itself of so-called national
security concerns means that in this
particular case the ban is upheld and
this isn't new right the use of
so-called national security to defend
policy has been used to justify
surveillance it has been used to justify
Wars and this is the for lack of a
better term trump card using national
security as a justification for whatever
you're doing is a sort of carte blanche
to get away with a lot of stuff in the
eyes of the supreme court and even of
lower courts because of the inclusion of
those words national security and that
makes the decision stunningly dangerous
from the Supreme Court the term pused
SAR gonna chair this they will be
thrilled they are thrilled but what are
we really celebrating if the argument is
we're celebrating that the United States
is safer because of this travel ban well
again these countries haven't sent
people to the United States who became
terrorists if the argument is we're a
better country by banning people I don't
see how and
most disturbing part of this entire
thing goes beyond the obvious targeting
of Muslims and it goes beyond the nature
of national security being a way to get
away with almost everything you want the
most disturbing part of all of this is
that it was a five-to-four decision and
Neel Gorsuch should not be on the
Supreme Court lot of people have
forgotten about this Pat but Merrick
garland was nominated with about a year
remaining in President Obama's second
term and Republicans refused to have
hearings they waited it out and they
eventually got Trump and they got
Gorsuch and they won they won I don't
need to mitigate in any way they won
there was also some hubris on the part
of the Democrats who thought that it
wasn't a big deal
Republicans were denying Merrick garland
a chance because Hillary Clinton was
gonna win anyway and she was going to
nominate someone who was progressive and
that person will get on the court was
that element of arrogance as well and
this is why the arguments about Trump
and Hillary would be the same I'm voting
third party or I'm not voting or I'm
voting Trump as a goof or whatever
justification people used to say it
doesn't matter whether Trump or Hillary
win because they're both status quo
politicians or they're both globalists
or whatever justification was used
Hillary Clinton would not have appointed
Neel Gorsuch and this decision would
have gone differently now of course
Hillary Clinton never would have
proposed the travel ban in the first
place so in a sense it's it's moot in
that way
this is why you've got a vote and when I
hear the ignorant and the stupidity and
the hubris as Pat pointed out of why
bother voting these people are all the
same it makes no difference they're all
for corporate campaign donations or
whatever I'm with you
they are mostly all for the status quo
when it comes to that but the supreme
court matters for generations this is
the bed we made and we're gonna have to
sleep in it and even if the two parties
are indistinguishable on 50% of the
issues that still leaves 50% of the
interview the issues where there are
distinct differences and we
can have those debates and win the
battle of ideas what you got to win that
battle of ideas that's really the big
thing here and right now there are major
major losses and casualties happening in
the Battle of ideas